jadot quoi trouver que pour faire partir
la fusée il suffisait de la laisser
tomber
alors les shadoks porte c'est décidé
heureusement qu'ils partent d'ailleurs
car depuis le temps qu'on en parlait
nous commencions à nous impatienter et
bien non il ne partait pas encore cette
fois
figurez vous que tout à coup les shadows
qui leurs ustensiles surpris d'étranges
convulsions il se tordait se déformer
puis maigri et des godets et à la fin
disparaissait il avait attrapé la
maladie
c'était
la maladie cosmique qui se promenait
dans les espaces interstellaires est
surpris quand il y avait des choses qui
ne lui plaisaient pas ou qui la gênait l
arrivée et n'entendait plus parler
or les shadows justement ça ne lui
plaisait pas tellement des animaux aussi
mal en décider disait on ne veut pas eu
de fabriquer des choses comme ça elle
n'allait tout de même pas perdre
chantons elle à surveiller des bêtises
pareilles alors les malheureuses bêtes
terrassé par le terrible fléau
disparaissaient les unes après les
autres
bientôt ils n'auraient plus la fin des
shadows ce que tu es avait sonné les
shadoks sont en train de disparaître
ils ont attrapé la maladie qui fait
rétrécir en ce temps là c'était facile
il n'y avait pas 36 maladie qu'il n'y
avait la maladie qui servait pour tous
pour les pieds ou les dons
pour la tête et même pour l'intérieur
quand un shadok marché dont la maladie
avec ses pieds tout d'un coup tu flop il
se rétrécissait et quand il marchait du
côté où il y en avait moins il serait
précisée - de sorte qu'ils se
rétrécissait pas partout de la même
façon
c'était amusant ses pattes d'abord se
tendaient où se ramollit c'est la pauvre
bête se traîner lamentablement comme ça
et puis au bout d'un certain temps les
intérieurs étaient attaqués le chat d'oc
tout entier se grattait maigrissait
maigrissait et à la fin disparaissait le
devin pont bien en principe les réparer
avec son robinet magique qu'ils disaient
en réalité les jetait tout simplement
gucht
le professeur shadow coup de son côté en
profiter pour lui faire de la
concurrence
il avait soi-disant mis au point un
vaccin ainsi maladie mais les shadoks
inoculé se gonfle et se gonfler et à la
faim éclater c'était encore plus
accusant d'esclaves contourner du point
de vue de la santé
si cela continuait le problème du voyage
sur la terre faut que le voyageur allait
être définitivement résolus la planète
shadoks est infestée par la maladie
cosmique les uns rétrécissent les autres
grâce aux vaccins du professeur shadow
qu éclate
pendant ce tour dans le cosmos le jpy
son chapeau pilotait la fusée comme un
fou sans s'occuper de rien et foncer
droit sur la planète shadoks et la
terrible maladie
malheureux ce n'est toujours pour un
chat d'oc
il voulait retourner dans sa famille il
voyait des lumières sur la planète xiao
qu'ils croyaient qu'on tirait des feux
d'artifice pour l'accueillir qu'elle
s'était pas ça du tout c'étaient les
shadoks inoculé qui éclatent est de loin
bien sûr ça faisait bien mais de près
la maladie d'abord les contaminer elle
est réfléchie c'est ils ne mouraient pas
tous mais ceux qui survivent est le
professeur chat de compte c'était du sud
lui pour les inoculé
les shadoks évidemment essayer de se
cacher se camoufler en n'importe quoi en
passoire
en ressort deux lits poêle ou un
arrosoir pour échapper au terrible fléau
ou vaccins des professions shadow co
mais rien n'y faisait et la maladie la
situation est désespérée
l'egypte y vont tomber dans la maladie
les shadoks pour y échapper se déguise
en passoire où on ressort de lits mais
la maladie venait à bout des ressorts
s'infiltrait dans les passoires des plus
étranges s'infiltrait dans le golfe
découvrez d'énormes réserves de shadocks
qu'elle rétrécissait beaucoup périr et
nourrit du shadow que la maladie
redoublé de vigueur et de méchanceté si
bien qu'à la fin la planète elle-même se
mit à rétrécir d'autres péri
mais voyez comme les choses sont
drôlement fait le gie beef ou dans la
fusée hoyaux que la planète rapetisser
crier mais je le recul je recule et il a
versé des commandes si bien qu'ils se
mettaient à reculer pour de vrai élégie
vie furent sauvés mais pour les shadoks
c'était autre chose
les pauvres bêtes panis qui sautait dans
la puce et sont même compte le temps de
se changer
les shadoks bombe a sauté dans la leur
or la fusée d'euros qui était un endroit
ne marchait pas à l'endroit
tandis que la fusée donc bas qui était
allongé ne marchait pas à l'envers c'est
à dire que j'ai une certaine mesure elle
marche est alors en droit et d'autres
encore ce qui tombait aux descendants
essayer de s'agripper à ceux qui tombent
et remontant bien il se hissait sur les
ustensiles qui flottait entre temps à
force de manger trop de shadocks la
maladie était tombé malade et laissa
partir
rescapés et les uns ont tassé dans des
tiroirs les autres dont des casseroles
ou des passoires
c'est ainsi que commença pour eux le
long et pénible voyage qui devait en
principe les amener sur la tête au début
chez les shadoks la vie était belle
il y avait pas de balade il faut dire
d'ailleurs qu'il n'y en avait pas
tellement besoin de maladie les
activités normales de la vie quotidienne
shadoks suffisent est assez largement à
en faire périr un bon nombre de morts
plus ou moins violentes
et quand ça suffisait pas déjà d'autres
volontaires étaient désignés pour être
prêts passés d'office par le truchement
d'ustensiles spécialement prévu et tout
était pire figurez vous qu'un jour les
shadoks leurs êtres chers et de
résistance est une pure pouces
d'étranges compte
les un salon guissé s'étiolait les
autres c'est malheureux ce cadet et se
scléroser se rabougrissent les bons
jours était finie savez attrapé la
maladie
plus exactement c'est la maladie qui les
avaient attrapé car la maladie visé dans
les espaces interstellaires et dès qu'il
y avait quelque part une nouvelle
planète bien beurré d'habitants qui
apparaît c'est top
elle faisait dans le temps et elle en
faisait ses choux c'était une bestioles
bizarres biscornus et bâti muller qui
avait les mêmes propriétés rae avantages
d'un abord sauf qu'elle était vivante
avec subreptice ecotel elle sautait le
donnant sur un lot de shadocks rase et
onu et sauvagement elle inaugurait des
bourbonnais à bras raccourcis
ils ont bourré à sa wii halloween au
moule ils ont été tellement de mal a dit
qu'il n'en restait même plus assez pour
mourir de façon normale et officiels si
on peut dire alors il dire qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose et que demain matin
à la première heure s en occuperait sur
le bus près à condition que d'ici là ils
soient pas tous trépasser maintenant
qu'elle les avait rencontrés la maladie
cosmique fondée sur les shadoks à bras
raccourcis ils ne mouraient pas tous
remarqué mais tous étaient frappés
gde ce n'était plus que podologie
posologie astrologie et migraines
névralgies viatique et lumbago est à
fébrile et grippaux chez les autres ce
n'était que nécrosés interrogeons sim
aux call used une fois ces sites est
caniculaire cirrhose du sein fibrose
astronomiques aux dispose plus souvent
tonge et autres champignons de la même
faille le reste enfin devenait vieux
avant l'âge ce qui revenait exactement
au même la vieillesse étant comme chacun
sait une maladie comme les autres
la preuve c'est qu'on en donne
si on ne trouvait pas quelqu'un de plus
futés la maladie avant peut elle les
ferait tous crever c'est pourquoi les
shadoks organisé un grand concours de
beauté pour trouver le chat d'oc le plus
intelligent astucieux et futée celui-là
s'occuperait de la maladie et les guérir
le jour du concours était arrivé mais
alors là si tu peux on s'aperçut qu'il
n'y avait pas d' examinateurs c'était
obligé puisque dans tout concours
d'intelligence en principe vous avez
remarqué
il n'a plus intelligent qui peut juger
or celui là il n'avait pas trouvé
nécessairement vu qu'il faisait un
concours pour ça tout justement on
allait repartir sans savoir
or un shadok se leva et scrabble shadoks
mes frères feillu a confiance
je me suis auto examiner et en toute
objectivité
c'est moi
chef
moi-même et personnellement qui suit le
plus intelligent et au wifi confiant
l'abord primo parce que personne ne
pouvait prédire
secundo il ya ensuite parce que si
quelqu'un avait essayé de le prouver
bien lui il avait le pardon il fut nommé
grande intelligence heures générale est
reconnue d'utilité publique
avec ça la maladie n'avait plus qu'à
bien se tenir
legrand intelligence heures et docteur
shadoks reconnu d'utilité publique avait
été choisi pour venir à bout de la
maladie
le choix n'était pas mauvais c'est elle
qui en effraie l'inventeur de ce qu'on a
appelé depuis le marteau thérapeutique
et anti bruit quand une mécanique
quelconque shadow cloud ne marchait pas
ou faisait trop de bruit
il est réparée avec son marteau terra
petit car tel était son principe pour
bien dire quelque chose qui ne marche
pas ou qui fait trop de bruit
il faut il suffit de taper dessus avec
quelque chose qui marque lion qui fait
plus de bruit et dans tous les cas c'est
éradique à part son marteau une autre
tête aussi dans son poulailler une
bestiole bizarre elle répondait la
bestiole au doux nom de médecine en
temps normal sont plus de malades
brillamment la médecine shadoks ne
servait assez précisément tard qu elles
restent entourées néanmoins de toute la
considération et des égards dus à sombre
entre temps elle prenait des bains de
pieds
c'est dire qu'elle menait une vie
excessivement sibari ticket byzantine
bien qu'on a sorti quelques fois à seule
fin de tondre le gras sont et de faire
la vaisselle pour ne pas qu'elles se
rouille la médecine legrand intelligent
sur générale est reconnue d'utilité
publique dit qu'il voulait bien
s'occuper des shadoks malade mais qu'au
préalable il allait falloir les démons
dit pour voir d'abord comment il
marchait
les gens n'étaient pas très chauds
évidemment c'est pourquoi un shadok
volontaires fut commis d'office pour
être démontée décortiqué disséquer des
farcis et éventuellement guéri il fut
nommé malades professionnels et
officiels et grâce à lui on viendrait
certainement à bout de la maladie le
malade officiel shadoks partaient tous
les matins à la sorbonne
les shadoks se livrer sur sa personne à
l'étude de l'anatomie comparative et des
intégrales sous la direction du grand
intelligent général
flanqué de sa fidèle médecine on le
démonte et soigneusement pour voir
comment ils étaient faits de temps le
soir comme on était pressé on le
remonter un peu comme on pouvait
naturellement il avait déjà doc qui
trichait et qu'il gardait pour eux à
tout hasard soit à pied soit même une
patte entière sans compter que la
médecine quelquefois chiper les plus
beaux gosses aux rentrées dans ses
foyers
la malheureuse bête la plupart du temps
ne dormaient que d'un oeil
étant donné que l'autre bien souvent on
avait oublié de lui augmenté et le
lendemain on recommençait
on y injecter votre tout des vaccins
divers tels que fermeture éclair
épingles de nourrice ou aiguilles à
tricoter pour voir quelle maladie ça
allait lui donner
être malade officiel chesnais shadoks
était un dur métier sa bouille alors
c'était un dur métier quand la
malheureuse bête était un peu trop
fatigué par son travail on lui donner
des pilules pour le tranquilliser
ça leur montée vous pouvez suivre et le
sua de nouvelles expériences tout à fait
intéressant il prenait son équipe
tellement au sérieux que quand il
n'était pas malade il trouvait qu'il
n'était pas bien dans st il se disait
que s'il n'était pas malade même pendant
ses heures de loisirs c'est qu'il n'est
pas vraiment son métier et ne méritait
pas la confiance de ses supérieurs
de sorte qu'en plus des maladies conflit
faisait attraper pendant la journée il
en emporter des supplémentaires pour à
kapelle soir chez lui vous dire si les
connaissances shadoks avec tout cela
avance est à grands pas là comme on n'en
sait rien mais en tout cas ça les amuse
et bien et c'est encore à étudier
comment marcher la tête des shadoks
avait un sérum tout près paris sérum
terrible qui parait-il faisait réfléchir
on verrait bien s'il malades s'en sortir
et à des fins purement expérimental des
châteaux qui avaient inoculé à leurs
malades officiers l'insérant terrible le
sérum qui fait réfléchir et via sa
marque chez le chat d'oc déjà se
convulse est il réfléchissait
et le voilà maintenant qu'il se mêlait à
délirer être 10 et il ne pas être
continue-t-il
voilà la question savoir si les plus
nobles aux shadoks de souffrir les coûts
et les flèches de l'outrageuse fortune
ou de prendre les armes contre cette
marée de troubles et en s'opposant
défini
c est pas sûr non plus le sujet elle
réagissait lui parfaitement mourir dix
et il dormir continuait-il rien d'autre
et par un somme poncet finir ce mal du
coeur et les milliers de choc naturelles
qui sont le long de la chair c'est une
consommation qu'on espère dévotement
mourir dormir dormir par chance à rêver
mais dans ce rêve de mort quels rêves
viendront forme il suffit qu'une la
chaîne oxygen bagarre c'est la question
qui fait la vie si belle à la calamité
car qui sut portrait des coûts du thon
l'oppression de l'oppresseur l'orgueil
de l'orgueilleux les mépris comme
j'étais medal longueur du droit l'as
olemps des gens en place et l'écouté que
le mérite passion subi de l'incapable
alors qu'il peut se délivrer de tout ça
d'un simple côtoya le sérum décidément
faisait merveille tout tissu portrait
comme ça et j'ai mis les suisses ou une
ville honte mais la crainte de quelque
chose après l'amour cette contrée 1
découvertes tout nu le voyage ne reçoit
jamais revenu table l'esprit et nous
fait préférer supporter ces mots là que
fuir vers d'autres dont on ne sait rien
si la réflexion fait de nous tous des
lâches
ainsi la décision perd sa couleur native
dans les bals ténèbres de la réflexion
mais t'es où nous voici venir la belle
fille eh bien c'était gagné le shadow
cumulé était tout à fait qu'ils
récupérables donc conclusion la plus
grave maladie du cerveau c'est de
réfléchir il des critères que dorénavant
et ne réfléchirai plus du tout et que de
toute façon ça serait interdit la
planète shadow qui était vierge haineuse
mais déjà il y avait des ratés la
maladie déjà rageusement ravagé les
shadoks malgré eux périssaient pour
venir à bout du truc
legrand intelligent sur shadox était
adjoint 360 18,25 professeur à d'autres
lesquels était assisté de six demi
douzaine ennemis des peuples nourrissent
du moins agrégé d'histoire de
philosophie de shadow cologie et de
touré machin qu'on peut imaginer plus
une chienne de honte chasse répondants
ingénument au nom de médecine etc et des
désespérés mundo pts etc avec des
lunettes vous parle
ques malades officieuse ça devenait tous
les matins pour se faire démonter jusque
dans ses plus intimes interstices parler
3879 et quelques jadot co médecine et
épingles à nourrice dûment habilités à
traquer les arcanes des us et coutumes
de cette salle aux manades
mais malgré des efforts des 370 milles à
169 et pas de nourrice et auprès
sparadrap du mandat grille des études
d'anatomie piétinaient legrand
intelligent sueur et si shadow kuni
autres avec quick la médecine hope rdc
lunettes
samareh donahue repas + baisons cssa doc
qui ne se décrypte pape à l'extérieur se
mettait un continent à ceux décrits pire
darlène se réveiller le matin muni d'un
prospère le cérébral chronique est
tenace ça les oblige à réfléchir pour le
restant de la journée de façon tout à
fait indiqué ado pestis certains au
creuset souvent même avant la fin de
l'après midi déjà togo avait bien
remarqué que quand on démonte et le
malade officiel il y avait des petits
trucs machins et on gagne mais comme la
médecine de garde qui voyait rien il ne
se cachait pas la tête et balayé les
collègues et la nuit les petits trucs il
est petit machin ne restez pas dans
l'est
depuis que les chats d'augmenter et
démonter le château qu'officiel ils
avaient bien remarqué qu'il y avait des
petits trucs tomber avait pas les rues
dans les coins mais les petits trucs et
les petits machins eux restés pas tomber
quoi souder à la gorge de la voix de
bahts shadoks qui passaient et pour la
peau des petits machins là c'était de la
maladie et la médecine en y regardant de
plus près toute l'europe qu'elle est
évident que c'était et oui que c'était
des gènes et shadow qu'on avait connue
de gégène autrefois sur la terre et pas
des moins féroce que vous vous souvenez
intervalles réguliers les gènes de
l'univers se mettaient tambour pour
aller traquer du chat d'oc ou tout juste
ont-ils allure plus ou moins vivante et
s'installe et dedans quand un gène et sa
famille allaient dans un shadok de
somsois taboury limete chauffage central
la température de la malheureuse bête
obligatoirement monter ça lui cherche
une juge inique carabine à sept îles
baie terre et cubitus à la place des
humains russe parce que pour le confort
ça les arrangeait il mettait de la
moquette dans l'ira tu es lire nous et
on faisait leur salon s'installait dans
le chat d'oc des piscines et des
ascenseurs et se faisait des orgies de
globules shadoks blocs où selon les
goûts et quand ça suffisait pas et de
planter des champignons de l'intérieur
gégéne mans par l'eau ça faisait bien
mais de l'extérieur pour le chat d'oc
ça l'était beaucoup moins au bout de six
semaines
c'était plus deux ou trois gégène qu'il
y avait là dedans et des hordes et des
défis nés j'aime mieux vous dire
quand le chat d'oc devenez un peu trop
toute idée l'abri faisait sauter tout le
bidule est allé s'installer dans un
autre plus gras et bien dodu et doté de
toutes les commodités en ou gaz
électricité ça recommençait et au bout
de deux ou trois mois selon la frénésie
génique les hommes qui sont si l'ag
génie tu continuer toute la planète
bientôt parler sauter